und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend astrazeneca ist freigesprochen die
europäische medizin behörde erlaubt
jetzt den einsatz als impfstoff gegen
korona ohne jede einschränkung der
nutzen überwiegen die risiken so simpel
würde das nicht reich impfstoff wird
vielen millionen gesunden menschen
gespritzt
da muss der nutzen gewaltig und das
risiko minimal sein letztes jahr war für
menschen in deutschland das risiko an
koronaren etwa eins zu 1000 1000 das ist
nicht viel das ist ein verdammt hohes
risiko das risiko im zeitlichen
zusammenhang an einer sinus
venenthrombose zu sterben liegt dagegen
bei allenfalls 1 zu hunderttausenden und
dieser zusammenhang ist nicht einmal
bewiesen und so war die entscheidung
heute klar die sicherheits ausschuss der
europäischen arzneimittelagentur
bestätigt dass die vorteile des asta
celica impfstoffs mit 19 zu schützen
insgesamt die risiken von nebenwirkungen
über wie er heißt das nun diese
europäische entscheidung dass alle
länder europas jetzt ohne
einschränkungen astrazeneca für impfen
so viel sie kriegen können
die mahd heute mit ihrer
uneingeschränkten empfehlung den
eu-mitgliedstaaten quasi freie hand
gelassen
den impfstoff nach ihren eigenen
kriterien zu bewerten und die sind in
der europäischen union durchaus
unterschiedlich da ist einmal
deutschland dass er den impfstoff
vorsichtig handhabt sagt lieber nur für
menschen über 60 auch weil das reiche
deutschland es sich leisten kann auch
andere impfstoffe wie den von bayern
texaner noch zu verhelfen und
vorzuhalten
dann gibt es länder wie italien da gibt
es tage an denen 500 menschen an corona
sterben da flacht das risiko einer
seltenen venenthrombose deutlich ab hier
wird astrazeneca voll an alle verimpft
und es gibt länder wie dänemark die fast
überhaupt keine corona toten haben da
ist astra sie dicker als impfstoff
komplett ausgesetzt
wird deutschland jetzt ein
übervorsichtige außenseiter sein wenn
hier weiter nur über 60-jährige
astrazeneca bekommen in deutschland ist
gar nicht allein mit dieser einschätzung
ungefähr ein dutzend eu länder machen
das ähnlich wie deutschland handhaben
wie sie irgendwo vorsichtig auch um den
imkern keine neue nahrung zu geben und
die erstaunlichste wende hat heute
großbritannien vollzogen die ja bisher
überhaupt nicht als übervorsichtig
bekannt waren in sachen aus brasilia
weil der impfstoff ja auch in ihrem
eigenen land entwickelt wurde
die briten haben heute gesagt sie
wollten versuchen menschen jungen
menschen unter 30 astrazeneca nicht mehr
anzubieten weil das risiko für die an
corinna zu sterben so gering sei dass
man noch nicht mal eine seltene
nebenwirkung in kauf nehmen wollte ist
also alles eine frage der perspektive
und es gibt unterschiedliche in europa
dankeschön an der vorsitzende der
ständigen impfkommission wird im
heute-journal update später heute abend
gesprächsgast von nazan guckte mir sein
und dann hingeht dann die frage wie kann
das sein dass es bei ein und denselben
impfstoff unterschiedliche
altersempfehlungen weiterhin gibt
unterdessen ist in deutschland die
dritte wahrscheinlich die gefährlichste
infektionswelle einen ganzen tag weiter
gekommen ohne dass wesentliche
entscheidungen fielen es wurde weiterhin
mehr taktisch geredet als medizinisch
gehandelt frank buchwald bericht
eigentlich nur einen bildtermin
nordrhein westfalen nimmt das erste
drive im impfzentrum in betrieb corona
schutz ganz fix durchs autofenster in
diesen tagen aber hat alles was corona
betrifft politisch an doppelten boden
brücken lockdown und der kampf ums
kanzleramt ministerpräsident laschet
nutzt die gelegenheit meine idee liegt
auf dem tisch und alles andere werden
wir dann hoffe ich konstruktiv mit einer
gemeinsamen botschaft so schnell wie
möglich klären
der rivale aus bayern der laschet in den
letzten tagen ziemlich ramponiert hatte
handelt locker und verlängert von
vorgezogenen bund länder gipfel keine
rede mehr
ich plädiere sehr dafür dass wir sehr
konzentriert und zubereiten mit einer
klaren richtung denn nur sich zu treffen
um sich auszutauschen allein habe ich
wird dem ernst der lage nicht gerecht
sondern wir sollten dann noch mal auch
klarmachen ob es neue zusätzliche
aspekte gibt zu den bisherigen regeln
neue aspekte etwa aus den
intensivstationen die zahl der
kritischen corona patienten nimmt wieder
zu
wissenschaftler warnen wenn wir jetzt
nicht gegensteuern laufen wir schon
gefahr dass uns das dass uns die
intensivstation überlastet werden und um
das zu verhindern müssen wir noch mal
schärfere massnahmen beschliessen und
auch durchführen um einfach die
infektionen noch einmal auf ein minimum
zu reduzieren solche sorgen treiben wohl
auch die kanzlerin um sie befürworte
einen kurzen harten locker und lässt
merkel ihre regierung sprecherin
mitteilen
auch ein gemeinsames bundeseinheitliches
vorgehen wäre hier wichtig denn es geht
ja hier um gemeinsame maßnahmen
gemeinsames handeln das wäre
wünschenswert
die vielfalt der beschlossenen regeln
trägt im moment nicht zur sicherheit und
zur akzeptanz bei merkel denkt an ihr
bild in der geschichte die frage aber
wer nach ihr ins kanzleramt einzieht
bleibt offen wäre die union noch zögert
preschen die grünen vor
wir warten auf gar nichts wir haben
immer gesagt wenn wir das machen wollen
wie wir das machen wollen
da gibt es klarheit da ist eine
strategie dahinter und deswegen am 19
april ist es soweit und ich freue mich
darauf fährt
dadurch gerät die union in zugzwang ihre
offene k-frage nicht allzu lange offen
zu lassen
ein rat für die rivalen im westen und
süden kommt heute aus dem norden
das haben armin laschet und markus söder
ja auch angekündigt dass sie sich
zwischen ostern und pfingsten treffen
und zwischen ostern und pfingsten hat ja
jetzt schon angefangen von daher müssen
die beiden ja auch nicht zu lange warten
nächste politische station dürfte jetzt
erstmal ein weiterer bund länder gipfel
sein thema locker und wie dessen
entscheidungen sich aber auf wahlchancen
auswirken weil es noch niemand so genau
kroner politik hat eben immer einen
doppelten boden über den größten teil
von 2020 sah es so aus als könnte die
union in aller ruhe den nächsten kanzler
bestimmen nach dürren jahren erlebte die
kanzlerin partei seit beginn der
pandemie einen umfragen höhenflug der
ist erst mal vorbei
cdu und csu haben ein rücksturz in die
ebene hinter sich wo man keinen kanzler
mehr bestimmt sondern nur noch
kandidaten sprechen wir vor diesem
hintergrund über das duell söder laschet
professor thorsten faas erforscht
wählerverhalten und entscheidungen an
der freien universität berlin
guten abend herr vs angeblich liegt ja
söder im moment in der wählergunst
deutlich vor laschet was sagt einem dass
über das wählerverhalten in fast einem
jahr
ja ja ja das ist eine der berühmten
momentaufnahmen aber sie ist natürlich
trotzdem wichtig denn wir haben es hier
mit zwei sehr bekannten auch nicht neuen
politikern zu tun deren image sich nicht
kurzfristig ändern lässt insofern werden
die strategen in den landkreisen sich
schon sehr genau angucken wo die beiden
beliebt sind wo die beiden auch punkten
können und stand heute liegt so dass
schon sehr sehr deutlich vor laschet nun
hat ja laschet ganz raffiniert gesagt
man müsse das danach entscheiden wer von
beiden die besseren chancen in ganz
deutschland hat seinerzeit waren stoiber
und strauss in bayern unheimlich
erfolgreich aber sind beide im bund
gescheitert gibt es diesen unterschied
heute noch genauso kraftvoll ja das ist
erstmal bemerkenswert dass die beiden
sich jetzt auch ein stückweit
wechselseitig schlecht machen der eine
sagt ich bin besser an umfragen der
andere sagt naja aber wer weiß ob das
deutschlandweit geld sicherlich ist es
nicht mehr so dass ein bayerischer
kandidat überhaupt keine chance mehr
hätte aber wir haben auch bei den wahlen
in baden-württemberg und rheinland-pfalz
gesehen gerade auf der zielgerade
schauen sich die wählerinnen und wähler
dann die kandidaten doch noch mal sehr
genau an
insofern sind es auch an der stelle
momentaufnahmen wichtig erscheint mir an
der stelle nur noch zu sagen der blick
auf bayern wer also den rest der
republik es sind zwei parteien es sind
zwei organisationen und auch markus
söder braucht eine schlagkräftige cdu
insofern darf er die partei die cdu
gerade auch nicht zu sehr von grenzen
ich werde auch noch einmal auf die
situation im moment zurück kommen im
moment steht er alles unter diesen
bewiesen thema pandemie das hoffentlich
bis ende september seinen schrecken
völlig verloren hat da werden andere
themen im vordergrund stehen hatten wir
das je dass eine so veränderte lage dann
jetzt praktisch prophezeit werden muss
bei der auswahl der kandidaten
naja kurzfristige themen spielen immer
eine wichtige rolle das können
naturkatastrophen sein das können
außenpolitische ereignisse seien aber
sicherlich ist diese corona pandemie
aktuell von einer dominanz die für
andere themen keinen platz lässt
trotzdem ist es insofern wichtig für die
beiden kandidaten aber auch für die
wahlentscheidung bei der bundestagswahl
weil es ja auch um so metallelemente
geht wer weiß eigentlich gerade das
führungsstark es wer hat kompetenz wer
ist integer und glaubwürdig und selbst
wenn die pandemie verschwindet diese
merkmale einer persönlichkeit die
bleiben natürlich und insofern sind es
schon gerade auch entscheidenden momente
für die beiden kandidaten über die wir
sprechen aber natürlich auch die
parteien insgesamt nun war ja herr
laschet ein absolut auf dem papier sehr
geeigneter kandidat der ist der
regierungschef in nordrhein westfalen
das wäre wenn es alleine stünde das
fünftgrößte wirtschaftsland der
europäischen union
es hat schwer industrie landwirtschaft
digitalen wandel globalisierung das sind
alles themen mit denen er sich
beschäftigt hat und er kann wahlen
gewinnen er hat hannelore kraft
geschlagen die als nicht schlagbar galt
und jetzt wird sich stolz der in der
wählergunst zur enorm ab wie kann das
passieren und vor allen dingen ist das
dann von dauer
ja in der tat wir sehen hier ein muster
das wir schon häufiger gesehen haben
dass nämlich landespolitiker wenn sie
dann auf der bundesebene ankommen da
doch noch mal ganz anders gewogen werden
und dass sie dann auch sehr kritisch mit
jeder einzelnen aussage evaluiert werden
und es tut ihnen manchmal nicht gut das
fällt ihnen manchmal schwer
das sehen wir jetzt auch bei armin
laschet und die schwierigkeit ist
natürlich dieses momentum was gerade für
ihn nicht nach oben sondern doch sehr
deutlich nach unten zeigt das zudrehen
er hat jetzt ein image und ein solches
image zu wandeln
das ist ein kurzer frist nicht unbedingt
einfach im gegenteil das würde man dann
vielleicht sogar wieder gegen ihn
auslegen dass er jetzt versucht
kurzfristig da sich anders zu
präsentieren sein image zu wandeln das
ist wirklich eine sehr sehr schwierige
situation für ihn gerade und dann nützen
ihm diese früheren erfolge leider aus
seiner sicht gerade auch nicht allzu
viel
nun ist er markus söder durchaus ein
mann der in der vergangenheit
kehrtwenden hingelegt hat wenn der wind
sich gedreht hat und heute verkauft er
sich offenbar erfolgreich als der
geradlinige typ wie kurz ist das
gedächtnis der wähler in solchen phasen
wir haben den blick auf umfragen doch
offensichtlich sehr kurz aber das ist
eben eine entscheidende punkt wir wissen
nicht genau
wenn die wählerinnen und wähler dann
wirklich den wahltag vor augen haben
wenn sie erkannt haben dass es um die
nachfolge von angela merkel geht was sie
dann tun ob sie dann noch mal
nachdenken ob sie in sich gehen und ihn
dann vielleicht auch ein feld das man
früher einmal einen anderen markus söder
eine andere csu eine viel
konfliktträchtige csu gesehen hat so
fern ist das eine spannende frage wie
sich die aktuellen stimmungen jetzt
tatsächlich im september in stimmen
umsetzen werden
wenn wir eines aus baden-württemberg und
rheinland-pfalz gelernt haben dann
eigentlich das selbstverständlichkeiten
gibt es gerade nicht große vorsprünge
können verspielt werden und genau das
haben auch die unions strategie erkannt
deswegen ist die partei glaube ich
gerade doch sehr in der wo sieht
verhaftet dann werden wir sehen was
passiert im nächsten halben jahr bis zur
wahl hoffentlich nur gutes dankeschön
professor fast sehr gerne
und hier geht es weiter mit den
nachrichten und grunde lag auf die
korona krise belastet die öffentlichen
haushalte stark ausgaben steigen
einnahmen sinken das gesamtdefizit im
vergangenen jahr ist das höchste seit
der wiedervereinigung
bund länder gemeinden und
sozialversicherungen gaben 189 2
milliarden euro mehr aus als sie
einnahmen
die steuereinnahmen sanken im schnitt um
3 5 prozent die ausgaben stiegen um über
zwölf prozent ausgeglichen wurde das
defizit durch neue schulden in höhe von
über 130 milliarden euro
ein türkisches gericht hat knapp fünf
jahre nach dem putschversuch gegen
präsident erdogan urteile gegen fast 500
angeklagte gefällt 38 frühere
militärangehörige wurden zu lebenslanger
haft verurteilt 106 angeklagte erhielten
mehrjährige gefängnisstrafen
in 350 fällen gab es freisprüche oder
kein urteil
das mammut verfahren richtete sich gegen
mutmaßliche anhänger des islamischen
predigers kühlen den die türkische
regierung für den putschversuch
verantwortlich macht 2016 wurden dabei
251 menschen getötet und tausende
verletzt
in sachsen hat die affäre um einen
größeren munitions diebstahl durch
spezialkräfte der polizei personelle
konsequenzen der
lka-chef und der zuständige
abteilungsleiter müssen ihre posten
aufgeben
die generalstaatsanwaltschaft in dresden
ermittelt gegen 17 polizisten einer
spezialeinheit sie sollen 7000 schuss
munition aus polizei beständen entwendet
und damit ein nicht dienstliches
schießtraining bezahlt haben vor der
küste norwegens treibt weiterhin ein
niederländischer frachter ohne besatzung
und mit 350 tonnen schweröl an bord eine
geplante bergung musste
witterungsbedingt verschoben werden
die zwölfköpfige crew wurde bereits am
montag per hubschrauber gerettet nachdem
das schiff in seenot geraten war bei
heftigem wellengang hatten sich teile
der fracht verschoben
daraufhin geriet das schiff in
schlagseite was in deutschland und über
deutschland manche behaupten die stolz
darauf sind quer zum nachrichtenstrom zu
liegen dass nämlich die regierung unter
dem deckmantel von pandemie bekämpfung
bürger und menschenrechte abbaut
das ist in vielen ländern der erde keine
fantasie sondern bittere realität
das ist ein neuer und ziemlich
einmaliger aspekt des jahresberichts von
amnesty international
es besteht grund zur sorge zahlreiche
staaten darunter china belarus und wenn
es ul hätten die gesundheitskrise
missbraucht um weiter rechtsstaatliche
prinzipien aufzulösen kritisierte der
amnesty generalsekretär in deutschland
reicheren staaten warf amnesty vor in
der pandemie impfstoffe für sich zu
horten so seien bislang 85 prozent der
weltweit verkauften dosen in länder mit
hohem und mittlerem einkommen
verabreicht worden
in einkommensschwachen ländern waren es
demnach nur 0,1 prozent
besonders verletzliche gruppen wie vor
erkrankte menschen geflüchtete sowie
frauen und mädchen litten am stärksten
unter der pandemie so habe es
insbesondere in südamerika aber auch in
anderen regionen einen anstieg von
geschlechtsspezifischer gewalt gegeben
amnesty pranger zudem an dass
beschäftigte im gesundheitswesen in der
pandemie häufig schutzlos allein
gelassen würden
im vergangenen jahr starben demnach
weltweit mindestens 17.000 in diesem
sektor beschäftigte mit cupid 19
die pandemie hat auch die
mittelmäßigkeit und verlogenheit der
egoismus und den betrug unter den macht
haben dieser welt verstärkt schreibt die
amnesty-generalsekretärin im vorwort des
berichts verstärkt verstärken kann man
nur was es vorher schon gab
und wäre jetzt wieder einmal über das
schicksal von alexei navalny berichten
dann steht er für tausende aufrechte
aber weniger prominente schicksale
seit er sich gerade genesen von brutalen
giftanschlag dem russischen staat wieder
ausgeliefert hat hat er nur noch seine
prominenz als schutz
das ist nicht viel russlands machthaber
können darauf setzen dass er vergessen
wird hinter dem stacheldraht des
straflagers indem er jetzt für jahre
sitzen soll
schon jetzt ein paar wochen nach dem
urteil muss navalny offenbar ernsthaft
erkrankt zu letzten mitteln der
machtlosen greifen hungerstreik
christiansen bericht aufmerksamkeit
schaffen zumindest das können navis
unterstützer im moment noch für ihren
inhaftierten weggefährten erreichen viel
mehr aber nicht
eigentlich war anastasia wassiljewa
wallis hausärztin gemeinsam mit anderen
medizinern gestern zum straflager in
paragraph gekommen um sich selbst ein
bild zu machen von der wein ist
gesundheitszustand doch ins lager kam
sie erst gar nicht rein
wir werden morgen übermorgen wieder
hierherkommen bis sie uns rein lassen
und wir sehen was mit alexej passiert
bis er in ein normales krankenhaus
gebracht wird normale medizinische hilfe
und medikamente bekommt alexej nawalny
hier im schwarzen haft anzug aufgenommen
von einer überwachungskamera vor zwölf
tagen
seit ende märz ist russlands
bekanntester häftling im hungerstreik
in einem brief an den gefängnisdirektor
hatte er medizinische hilfe gefordert
sarkastisch formulierte er
ich habe mich an mein bein gewöhnt in
den vergangenen jahren ich möchte es
nicht verlieren
jetzt kamen auch noch fieber und husten
dazu bei drei mithäftlingen wurde
tuberkulose festgestellt sagt navalny
heute der nächste anlauf für einen
besuch diesmal von dabei nissan welten
sie durften ihn sehen und sind geschockt
zwei bandscheibenvorfälle sein
diagnostiziert worden
er hat weiterhin schmerzen im rücken und
in einem bein und er verliert das gefühl
in den beinen und auch in den händen
das lager in paragraph gilt als eines
der härtesten in russland im
staatsfernsehen zeichnet die propaganda
hingegen das bild eines ferienlagers die
botschaft hier lasse es sich leben
navalny übertreiben er wird an seinem
bett von dem kamerateam überrumpelt von
maria butina keine reporterin in den usa
wurde sie verurteilt wegen
agententätigkeit
navalny sagt du lügst alles was du
machst ist eine pr show scharfe kritik
an den haftbedingungen kommt heute von
amnesty international russland bringen
aber möglicherweise in die situation
eines langsamen todes die tatsache dass
er alle ein bis zwei stunden geweckt
wird ist eine form von folter dass er
keinen zugang zu einem arzt hat dem er
vertraut ist eine form von misshandlung
aus dem kreml heißt es knapp navalny
habe kein anrecht auf eine
sonderbehandlung für die ärztin vassili
war ihre begleiter und auch journalisten
endete der gestrige straflager besuch
übrigens mit einer festnahme
da war einiges unterstützer wollen
weiter für ihn kämpfen und riskiert viel
wassiljewa hatte noch eine drastische
frage wer muss man sein
um ärzten den zugang zu einem sterbenden
menschen zu verwehren
er versucht das vergessen zu verhindern
nachrichten noch mal von kunden der
deutsche automarkt kommt nur langsam aus
der korona krise zwar werden wieder mehr
pkw neu zugelassen als vor einem jahr
insgesamt aber bleibt der markt schwach
und weit unter dem vorkrisenniveau sina
mainitz allerdings stabilisiert sich der
trend zum elektroauto
ja so ist es im märz gingen die zahlen
deutlich nach oben elektroautos
erreichten ein plus von knapp 200
prozent verglichen zum vorjahr zwar ist
der benziner nach wie vor das
beliebteste auto aber die kräfte
verschieben sich langsam hin zu
umweltfreundlicheren alternativen
wichtig für die produktion von e autos
ist lithium ohne lithium keine
autobatterie
bisher war die förderung aber wenig
umweltfreundlich das soll sich jetzt
ändern ein karlsruher unternehmen will
nun das sogenannte gold der zukunft
fördern
denn ausgerechnet im rohstoffarmen
deutschland liegt das größte lithium
vorkommen der welt unter dem rheingraben
im thermalwasser in tausenden meter
tiefe über geothermie kraftwerke soll
der rohstoff schon bald co2 neutral und
umweltfreundlich gefördert werden
laut forschern böte das dortige
vorkommen genug metall für rund 400
millionen elektroautos jahrelang hinter
deutschland bei alternativen antrieben
hinterher
wurde vielleicht sogar belächelt allen
voran auch durch diverse abgas skandale
nun könnte sich eine dringend benötigte
trendwende abzeichnen nicht nur die
hersteller können im ersten quartal des
jahres deutlich zulegen
auch in sachen batteriezellen holen
deutschland und europa auf zurzeit sind
im großen stil neue zehn fabriken in
europa geplant im jahr 2030 könnte der
kontinent dann auf platz zwei hinter
china rücken
vielen dank sie nach frankfurt im us
bundesstaat florida ist eine befürchtete
umweltkatastrophe durch einen dammbruch
vorerst gebannt
einsatzkräfte haben die lage an einem
vom bersten bedrohten großen ab
wasserbecken unter kontrolle
gebracht sie konnten hunderte millionen
liter der mit phosphor und stickstoff
belasteten abwasser abpumpen um druck
von der gerissenen beckenwand zu nehmen
die sanierungskosten werden auf rund 200
millionen dollar geschätzt
eine meldung vom dfb pokal da steht
werder bremen im halbfinale nach dem 1 0
auswärtssieg bei jahn regensburg wegen
corona fällen war das viertelfinale auf
heute verschoben worden am 30 april geht
es für werder nun gegen rb leipzig und
hier sind die gewinnzahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten ohne gewähr
19 18 19 36 37 superzahl 0 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text und wir erinnern wieder einmal an
den april 1945
der totale krieg mit dem nazi
deutschland europa und die welt
überzogen hatte war zurückgekommen nach
hause das regime lag in letzten
zuckungen und richtete seine
zerstörungswut gegen das eigene volk
gegen menschen die den wahnsinn nicht
mehr ertragen und mitmachen wollten
sie traf noch einmal der fanatische
durchhaltewille des nazi apparats in
rahnsdorf einem ortsteil des zerstörten
berlin wurden todesstrafen verhängt und
sofort vollstreckt gegen frauen und
männer die nicht mehr und nichts anderes
verlangten als ein stück brot eine fast
schon vergessene geschichte christhard
läpple erzählt sie gespiegelt an
ramsdorf heute sechster april 45 kurz
vor kriegsende im berliner vorort
rahnsdorf verbreitet sich ein gerücht
brot gibt es nur noch für ns mitgliedern
hunderte allen zu den drei brand des
ortes zwei verteilen den leib zu 50
fanning beim zentralen becker weigern
sich die nazi träumen besitzer brot an
die bevölkerung zu verkaufen
der alarmierte ortsgruppenleiter hans
karte mann droht mit gezogener waffe
kann nicht verhindern dass brot den
besitzer wechselt die 45 jährige
margarethe 11 steht in der wütenden
menge weit vorne
vermutlich mit einem brot in der tasche
ich erinnere mich noch sehr genau wie
die familie allerdings nur sehr leise
darüber sprach und mit einem gewissen
erschrecken auch im gesicht die frauen
haben nichts anderes als brot verlangt
und sie habe kritische bemerkungen in
der anstehe
in der bäckerei ist tischlermeister max
heiliges mit reparaturen beschäftigt der
53-jährige sagt zum ns funktionär gibt
den frauen dort brot und da einen ruck
wirst du bald ausziehen müssen
stunden später nehmen die nazis rachen
frauen aus der nachbarschaft liefern
nahm ortsgruppenleiter gerate man meldet
sie als volksschädlinge der gestapo noch
am abend werden 15 menschen verhaftet
am folgenden tag verurteilt ein
standgericht margarete 11 lebt ihre
jüngere schwester gertrud und den
tischler heiliges als rädelsführer zum
tode
ein versuch an brot zu kommen das als
plünderung auszugeben und dann zu
todesurteilen zu kommen das denke ich es
selbst in der geschichte der
nationalsozialistischen herrschaft in
berlin und in deutschland etwas
einzigartiges joseph goebbels notiert in
seinem tagebuch am 8 april 45
so muss man vorgehen wenn man in einer
millionenstadt ordnung halten will und
die ordnung ist die voraussetzung der
fortsetzung unseres widerstandes
goebbels begnadigt in letzter minute die
36 jährige gertrud zu acht jahren
zuchthaus weil sie mutter von drei
kindern ist ihre ältere schwester
margarethe wird kurz nach
urteilsverkündung hingerichtet der
henker war extra in der nacht nach
plötzensee bestellt worden
genau wie tischler heiliges die strafe
für ein stück brot
[Musik]
ganz schlimm das war die rache der nazis
am eigenen volk
mehr als fünf jahrzehnte wurde der brut
aufstand von rahnsdorf vergessen
erst nach der wende brachten bürger 1998
eine gedenktafel an das haus wechselte
den besitzer und wurde renoviert die
tafel verschwand seit 2016 würden
versprochen endlich eine angemessene
erinnerung wieder anzubringen
das wäre wohl angebracht wir empfehlen
ihnen das auslandsjournal jetzt gleich
mit matthias fornoff und empfehlen uns
bis morgen heute journal update gegen
0.30 übrigens auch ein bericht vom spiel
der bayern gegen paris st
[Musik]
knaben meine damen und herren das hoch
peggy ist umzingelt von einigen tiefs
und jetzt wurde es ja noch mal sehr kalt
diese kühle luft und auch die
schneewolken die werden morgen hier
richtung südosten weggedrängt und dann
wird es ganz allmählich von südwesten
etwas wärmer und woher die wärme kommt
sehen wir auf den temperaturen für
morgen denn hier in spanien und portugal
auf den kanarischen inseln liegen die
werte morgen schon bei 20 bis 25 grad
sonst aber es ist ein ganz
kontinentaleuropa kalt und auch hier auf
irland liegen die temperaturen morgen
nur bei 10 grad genauso wie im schwarzen
meer nördlich von moskau ist es genau so
kühl wie nördlich des alpenlandes und
bei uns sinken die temperaturen in
dieser nacht meist in den frost von
minus 1 bis minus 4 grad und nur in
norddeutschland bleibt es etwas milder
heute nacht fällt noch schnee vor allen
dingen in der südhälfte und auch morgens
sie sich die schneewolken langsam dann
nach südosten zurück
unlängst und schneidet das noch in
sachsen und in niederbayern zwischen der
eifel und dem alpenrand und an den
küsten aber scheint häufig die sonne bei
west wird die höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen zwischen 2 grad im westerzgebirge
und elf grad am oberrhein
aber schon am freitag steigen die werte
auf 7 bis 19 grad am samstag schüttet es
dann ganz ergiebig im westen
deutschlands bei temperaturen von sieben
bis 19 grad und am sonntag gibt es eine
wetter zweiteilung mit stark bewölktem
himmel und viel regen im nordwesten und
mit sonne und 20 grad im südosten
schönen abend noch